so let's talk a little bit of physics
maybe let's ask the uh the biggest
question what is
a theory of everything in general
what does that mean yeah so i mean the
question is can we kind of
reduce what has been physics as a
something where we have to sort of pick
away and say do we roughly know
how the world works to something where
we have a complete formal theory
where we say if we were to run this
program
for long enough we would reproduce
everything
you know down to the fact that we're
having this conversation at this moment
etc etc etc
any physical phenomena any phenomena in
this world phenomenon in the universe
but the you know because of
computational irreducibility
it's not you know that's not something
where you say okay you've got the
fundamental theory of everything
then you know tell me whether you know
uh lions are going to eat tigers or
something
you know that's a no you have to run
this thing for you know 10 to the 500
steps or something
to know something like that okay so at
some moment
potentially you say this is a rule
and run this rule enough times and you
will get the whole universe
right that's that's what it means to
kind of have a fundamental theory of
physics as far as i'm concerned
is you've got this rule it's potentially
quite simple we don't know for sure it's
simple
but we have various reasons to believe
it might be simple
and then you say okay i'm showing you
this rule
you just run it only 10 to the 500 times
and you'll get everything
in other words you've kind of reduced
the problem of physics to a problem of
mathematics so to speak
it's like it's as if you know you like
you just generate the digits of pi
there's a definite procedure you just
generate them and it'll be the same
thing if you have a fundamental theory
of physics of the kind that i'm
imagining
you you know you get a this rule
and you just run it out and you get
everything that happens in the universe
so a theory of everything is
a mathematical framework within which
you can explain everything that happens
in the universe it's kind of in a
unified way
it's not there's a bunch of disparate
modules of
does it feel like if you create a rule
and we'll talk about the wolfram
physics model which is fascinating but
if if you
if you have a simple set of rules with a
with a data structure like a hypergraph
does that feel like a satisfying theory
of everything
because then you really run up against
the
uh irreducibility computational
reducibility
right so that's a really interesting
question so i i i
you know what i thought was going to
happen is i thought
we you know i thought we had a pretty
good i had a pretty good idea
for what the structure of this sort of
theory that's sort of underneath space
and time and so on might be like
and i thought gosh you know in my
lifetime so to speak we might be able to
figure out what happens in the first 10
to the minus 100 seconds of the universe
and that would be cool but it's pretty
far away from
anything that we can see today and it
will be hard to test whether that's
right and so on and so on and so on
to my huge surprise although it should
have been obvious and it's embarrassing
that
it wasn't obvious to me but but um to my
huge surprise
we managed to get unbelievably much
further than that and basically what
happened is
that it turns out that even though
there's this kind of bed of
computational irreducibility
that sort of uh these all these simple
rules
run into there is a there are certain
pieces of computational reducibility
that quite generically occur for large
classes of these rules
and and this is the really exciting
thing as far as i'm concerned
the the the big pieces of computational
reducibility
are basically the pillars of 20th
century physics
that's the amazing thing the general
relativity and quantum field theory
the sort of the pillars of 20th century
physics turn out to be
precisely the stuff you can say there's
a lot you can't say there's a lot that's
kind of at this irreducible level
where you kind of don't know what's
going to happen you have to run it you
know you can't run it within our
universe et cetera et cetera et cetera
um but the thing is there are things you
can say
and the things you can say turn out to
be very beautifully
exactly the structure that was found in
20th century physics
namely general relativity and quantum
mechanics and
general relativity and quantum mechanics
are these pockets of reducibility
that we think of as that that you know
20th century physics is essentially
pockets of reduceability
and then it's it is incredibly
surprising that any kind of model
that's generative from simple rules
would have would have such pockets yeah
well i think
what's surprising uh is we didn't know
where those things came from
it's like general relativity it's a very
nice mathematically elegant theory
why is it true you know quantum
mechanics why is it true
what we realized is that from this
that they are these theories are generic
to a huge class
of systems that have these particular
very unstructured
underlying rules and that's the that's
the thing that is sort of
uh remarkable and that's the thing to me
that's just
it's really beautiful i mean it's and
the thing that's even more beautiful
is that it turns out that you know
people have been struggling for a long
time you know how does general
relativity theory of gravity
relate to quantum mechanics they seem to
have all kinds of incompatibilities
it turns out what we realized is at some
level they are the same theory
you